alri My Name Is Dennis van der steld and
If you're all the way in the back This
Is What I look like but it's not that
interesting neither is it that I'm
working for particular software The
Company That makes and service bus
because we  're here for microservices and
we want to see uh what microservices how
They Can Help us and how we build
microservices and Maybe via docker and via
kuber
Containers in
general
containers Any that oc I Don't I isti
even dist not Every col is distributed
correctly I don't ship Looks
Like Fabulous
tours
Looking
solan system the perfect
Architecture Looking architectural
Solutions
Styles are we even develop
sare
peras is Because Of The Maintenance c we
Build this system thatti Looks
Beautiful eventually There Always it
grows larger and larger There is a  lot
of Maintenance Cost And that doesn't
Mean that
costy
his over Time Where initi we thought we
had the perfect Architecture but it
didn't really work and We Can try docker
and We Can Try serverless Azure
functions and AWS lambas but It Doesn'  t
really help and now we have
microservices and Let's see if that
Might help Us build a better
Architecture build a better system
That's better maintain But first i'
Always like to go A few steps Back and
see
History how we h
we introduced microservices
My hiss
hu4
top
[Music]
gam joystick and When I Stood Up I
always took A few steps Back as If I Had
to for in the game and I pulled My M6 of
the table
Whatever Anyway This Was The Game This
Was What the cartridge looked like and
at some Point I decided to see what
happens if I Started up the computer
Without The cartridge so I took It Out And
I was presented with this and a nice
book and I learned to do print Hello
world and go to 10 and This Was The End
result
M that These movies w released can Any
Guess Year
was I always 84 I don't
know There some Magic on screen That
makes everyone 84 85 that was second
Guess
85 This Was What I like Back in 85 When
I was already programming and I  loved It
What I didn't know was that I was
programming in procedural Right with 10
20 30 and go to and Gos All Over The
Place I was programming in Basic but
foren and cob were similar types of
languages ​​And To Me I was in Heaven
Unicorns Rainbows And Everything and I
Wrote the best code ever The Thing Is
The More Lines of codes that I Wrote What
I didn't know was I Started writing
spaghetti coat Right When I was that
Young I Had no Idea What spaghetti coat
was and I  also didn't know that someone
Said the go to statement was considered
harmful the person Who initi Coin this
he came from My Hometown Rotterdam was
Dijkstra I don't know you know him he
Said we should All do structured
programming so Early 7S I was  even born
yet we got If statements While loops
functions and When People Started doing
that Everything was Rainbows in Unicorns
Again Until Some People thought we can
Still do Better so in 80s Around The 80s
we got object oriented programming and
lots of stuff like
classes polymorphism inheritance  the
most important thing I that was
introduced oi programming was
encapsulation right We were For The
First Time really Looking How We Could
Get High cohesion And Low
cing so we build Beautiful Systems with
classes and objects and I don't know
what else and we had  lots of classes
Calling other classes and this
introduced Us to something new Which was
If We Changed Something Somewhere In Our
code even though we thought that we had
Proper
encapsulation Somewhere that elsewhere
That We didn't even Touch suddenly broke
Right Apparently There w Still weak
links To All the code That We didn't
Expect to Break and Weed encapsulation
but we ended up with procedural code
Again even though we thought We were
doing object oriented programming We
Still created spaghetti
code cing was Us Down dependent Breaking sy
over over
we  Component model Don box famous for it
book on it stu
it now we classes that called everywhere
We Still had Them but we also had
components and we thought We Could
componenti Everything I don't know any
remers Lay arch we
ined
to
B Always end up  with Presentation and
Business and data Layer These w actually
in our code we had components Inside Our
layers and Those Calling each other All
The Time ETC
et I was introduced to this Type of
Architecture I Had layers over over
Again most of the time it s we  Sometimes
Skip The serv Layer or Back then we It
the process
Layer we didn't Dare Call Sorry Skip
business Layer Because We thought That's
basically A you can Never do even If We
built a website and we had this login
thingy where I Had to retrieve  some
usame
layers These of introducing all layers
separ in As components
or Whatever that I Had to go through
these days I try to call my databases as
soon as possible but Back in the day
when I was introduced into layers and I
was this Age anymore I  can find a More
recent picture
i wasing
archit archit
do
archit Business and The Business needs
to your software Architecture however No
matter what project I was on I always
ended up with These layers so I really
Question like What's the benefit of all
those layers They were  talking about
separations of concern and I don't know
what else I was convinced And then we
web services service oriented
Architecture
2 was
enthi was all my also already mentioned
dono writing books about com Do you know
Which framework he released after
starting over three times  Again Within M
Microsoft best framework
ever
wcf
Windows Communication
foundation
even
WF
[Music]
w Go Back To The Future back to 85 When
I was this boy I Tell Don't get an
STD If Dutch is Kind of weird because it
translates to sd but  Whatever Anyway The
Thing was at the same Time That We were
trying to introduce service oriented
Architecture into Our Systems And
Everything There w other people trying
Tove a
Different
by companies
lerut more and more
stuff Systems Need Talk to each other
that was a lot of work  People were
trying to solve system
integration This Was The Rise of the
Enterprise service bus or Better known
as B server IBM webs ETC They had this
solution
to
invented is web
services Enterprise service liter serv
in must me We the web
services we shaped form That
We  web
servic Maintenance nightm introduced of
others if you work with wcf and a lot of
you have you probably know Which Kind of
problems but Anyway we decided that this
was not a solution to Our problems and
grady boot The Father of uml he
basically Had this All  figured Out
earlier than a lot of other
people this
soa coned RB
Any The Thing We did with web services
is we Thing Kinds Of BLS except Now They
were All Out Of process so We Started
doing Network calls even if it's on the
same computer we had  serial to xml and I
don't know what else and we had web
services Calling web services we
introduced a Ton of latency And that was
part of the Another Thing was classified
was reuse You Could build like this
business Component And then reuse it in
some  other system and this sed really
promising I don't know how many people
Did that Here With wcf but the only
example that I Ever Found was look up
for postal codes so that didn't really
work well There Was One Thing though
with service oriented  Architecture And
that was the boundaries I don't know if
anyone remembers The Four tenets from
Don boox one of them was you shouldn't
cross service boundaries And Back in the
Day I Had no Idea What He Was talking
about I thought I was but  I Wasn't and
the reason you can't cross boundaries
was Because We were looking for the
encapsulation Within Our code I'll Get
Back To This later Anyway I think
Another Thing was That We Started Out
With classes for the encapsulation we
moved over  to bigger and bigger things
and ended up with Services
microservices
example we Back History i m service
Architecture I application users consult
dat
modif
already mention this to session do
microservices her was are you and then
the next was
are I that to
asic Us dat
I
spad Idea  Because The user Interface
Need Request The
data at some point there w some users
that could Only see small part of the
data or modify certain amounts of data I
went Back to the architect Again Said
This Is
working
Layer logical Layer Whatever We came up
with this  we decided to add Another
Layer because That's Always a good Idea
Right ke and Po already had this figured
out quite Sometime before I did
Apparently and I Still implemented It
This Way and this is what the Developers
to because They had Come all of
tricks
data I  this I was definitely Doing It
Wrong and it definitely
Hur And then microservices came along
and obviously This Was The solution To
All Our problems First of all There Was
no soap xml and xsd anymore that was
already a huge win Because The code was
Fine It was  the xml that was
the the Thing Is we Jason and swagger
and Swager client and gra and I don't
know what else and this was so much
Better and together with docker Which
was also introduced and kubernetes Right
Everything Was A Blast and we Now had
microservices Calling microservices and
this is what Lea Porter also mentioned
This Morning we ended up with
distributed monoli most of the time Just
introducing lots and lots of latency and
Simon Brown also regular
example is on overflow
was the I Buil My entire system
According to microservices
Architecture  his was What did I do Wrong
Every single
[Music]
Time
The com was
best I don't know that much about mic
Services 30k seems a Too Much Anyway It
Was unlikely that he Could Be helped
anymore The Thing Is he ended up with
Something  like this
probably I don't know any rec this
animation
[Music]
Sorry
Yes
Netflix they make More Money than I [
Laughter]
do They are highly
successful the Thing Is We all want to be
as successful as
Netflix we don't have
Us  most Of Us are in a very Different
business domain Next To That We have
Almost no Idea How They actually Set Up
The microservices what they using it for
if it's Architecture They use all over
the place or Only in places Why They
are using it in certain
places
seen
pattern
to we
guidance
Weeren is that
bad is I
Technology is Let's debunk some of the
microservices This Was One Of The Best
One Right you Couldn't write More Than
an x ​​Number of Lines of code luckily
that was dropped quite Fast because It
didn't make Sense If You Wanted to use
some do some data Access and use Maybe I
don't know what for it and security and
what else of we could small
function
Dr xml versus Jason we Drop The
xml because Jason is much Better you
clearly see Jon is much Better
Right Maybe someone can Explain It
Because I really Get It Jason is so much
Better I know
Less Apparently
People deak
hand leftover prev
conference
More Jon
ofm x and XY
xslt Who
didn't create Their we from
xml Anyway It's  funny because Jason Now
gets more and more and more features
like all these tools and Maybe It's
comparing Apples to oranges but More
like These Kinds Of Apples
eh I mean The technologies ar exactly
the
same are definitely
I'm not saying Jon B Sleeping Jon all
about the
xml the best part
is developer in the browser ex using
Javascript angular
React
javascript Often We Get data from the
database And then map it from relational
model to domain objects And then from
domain objects to data transfer objects
then to the View model and from  the View
model to Jason and then finally There's
No More mapping needed Because The
browser understand Jason so Go Jason
Maybe That's A solution to Our problems
however It Doesn't improve Our
Architecture Jason Isn't Bad and it's
definitely a good
Thing
everyone was Talking  microservices
saying I love it we use
Jon
Better
ex People microservices
I we spoke
in microservices
4 Seconds in Method do s that anymore
RPC procs It
Worse is it bad to service One Of The
Reasons is As long as
Waiting service Basic
B
depends
isit
[Music  ]
momy Calling
Services
ex
norm I pay Store I Myself decide How I
want to pay If I wan use My credit card
or Pay in Cash or Maybe a Combination
even moven didn't make that Decision he
handed over his Wallet and he got into
aot  of
problems
super bad Yes Excellent Any handover not
Money your business data you no longer
have the Authority over your own data
others start making decisions on your
data Which is yours and That's when you
Lose autonomy Don't
encs of dependency
isu
ex 300 microservices sh  I How data and
the data turns Out To Be
incorrect Right you don't know who
copied your incorrect data or Services
your data in the me invoices Have Been
calculated In some other Part Of The
System pays processed May Customer of
pays preferred
status based on  your incorrect data so
You're Not autonomous responsible
Anymore For Your data and if everyone
can just query your business data and
make decisions on it at some Point In
Time this is how youl be Looking At Your
Architecture Right And I'm not Again I  'm
not saying Throw Away RPC for Something
Else because RPC has Its Place I don't
know how you would Call your
data
Storage
RPC is server
to datab using
RPC definitely
other things other things theing is
happening Down
RPC
Time Throwing the word
AG operational  I don't El Mak
better
also make changes to schema to database
While the
system we take over servic
el
i
micr
mic op
department They to Deploy Our
microservices maintain Massive
infrastructure
monitor instead of doing one server
couple of servers They Do It 300 Times
over  They get the best Tos
ever kubernetes
ex Talking
deployment
isolated kubernetes make it e or
Whatever solution You're using makes it
easy to scale It Is Multi So you can
Pick Something up and Move It somewhere
else to Another region to Another data
center to Whatever  if it works on your
machine you can Just Deploy It some in
aure
whatever docker
ites
Run Architecture of
system
des
box is in
Run
Might
is it sprinkling do Magic over even do
ISES
Reasons
archit Let
ising We aeve High
Ling
First of all There's No Golden  Hammer
definitely not in technologies right I
think the answer is Right Here It's with
the audience in ndc I think we have to
take A few steps Back and look Better at
Those service boundaries that I was
talking about earlier and Finding the
right encapsulation right It's All  About
High cooling And Low cohesion and
layers compon web
Whatever I think we Looking At The
boundaries incorrect and knowing things
Together that ar highly cohesive and
That's Why we have Call each other
share
aeve low and High cohesion and it starts
When We listen to Our business  analysts
or product owners or Whatever We always
Been To Listen to the nouns and the
verbs They been saying nouns like
Customer and product and Order and Those
become entities in our system And then
we of the verbs ex
disc we Look we
introducing we all over the
tob That's Always doing it
architect Look at the nouns and the
verbs Maybe They Don't Tell You that but
they start drawing boxes and then they
hand It over to a developer and they
have to fill in The Blanks And The
Blanks Are With Our order  for example
Our
attributes Every order has a Customer It
has one or More Products Those Products
have
prices There's a Discount possibly and a
Shipping status and Once the Shipping
status is done then we know Our order is
completed
ehm for example product has prices If
product If  prices changes we can't have
the prices Change Inside Our order and
So on and So on so all of that has to be
in it and I think we need to look Way
More closely at Those attributes and we
need to ask ours if they have  to be in
the same transaction or share the same
consistency boundary That's that word
Again boundary ex Discount and
product What We Can Do Is Look at the
consistent requirements and State It as
a requirement and Maybe a really stupid
One Like if a zo if a Customer  has a
specific Discount They cannot order
Purple Products or Some Kind of product
or Whatever and your product owner or
business analyst will Tell You What are
you insane and That's When We Found Our
boundaries we have found Something that
doesn't share the same High consistency
as Another Thing
basically The Discount and product info
do not
Belong Together They Don't Belong Inside
a single Class or Whatever That's order
They are not
related They Don't share the same
transaction Let's Look at Another
example Price and Discount we
required a product  is on sale
2er is
promer 10
disc They Still get the Customer
Discount if the product is already on
Discount probably not
right They share the same consistency
boundary They share the same Little
Cloud thingy Whatever it
is
top is
ex
Customer shares the last name The Other
One is catalog item Shar some stuff And
then we have to look for example At The
Price and Discount They could go
together I Skip There Could Be other
entities like
aect
Discount we make
decisions attributes of Better
word We calculate the Discount for order
They to What  is I no
ide
exp
Shipping
stat Europe
customers
Days item
shing
is
we
introduce because otherwise Without Any
cooling There are Just things all over
the place that Can't Make Up a system
and we need to find the least volatile
Thing The Thing That Hardly ever  changes
if it at all ever changes and try to
couple The Things from the previous
slide
databases
weust
marketing
item
other things They Still do Job based on
identifiers these ches how we
traditionally define Our boundaries
Whatever we learned school University
whatever
Developers The features I know how  to
build It Let me just get to it but the
architect is taking a Decision and it
takes time right and it is a
Decision towards the right
Direction Because We should Make sure
that We Don't end up with
unable Nightmare Again Before It's Too
Late
harding Technology
to
They communicate Less because Why would
coe dealing with prices and discounts
need to talk to
Customer Their phone number Those
Services don't need share Any data
because They perfectly do the work to do
The
Other Why would code dealing with
delivery for example  needs to know the
price of the thing that it needs to
Deliver Right It shouldn't cross Those
boundaries Now If We Look at Our
monolith This Is Our traditional
monolith with a user Interface and
business Logic and data Storage and
Those logical layers are Always There
Right
instead What We always had was that
Every Layer was responsible basically
Everything and now with These High
consistency boundaries And Everything we
end up with More Vertical Pillars Right
And if we Take A Look At One Of Those
Vertical
Pillars and we Break it Down we Again
see Our
eh traditional logical
layers user Interface business Layer and
data Layer but they contain literally
Everything from micro views to micro
View Models to microcontrollers to I
don't know micro business Logic thing
and Whatever but each service is
responsible for everything from data to
user  Interface but then how do we
present against a unif sorry an
Interface a unified Interface That a
user can understand Right That's through
a Composite ui Where
Weil We Get The data we need from each
service It's Not Like There some Magic
Thing thats gathering data All Over  The
Place and Knows Where all the data is
because Every serv owns small part in
user
USS dat reside
Reve example If We have Our Amazon
website Again and I simplified It A
Little Bit you can imagine that the
title and the image of a book com from
the product catalog and I Named The
Services Here it's not necessary to give
Them Those names They could on Any
ecommerce website Different
names
ex user reviews Might
marketing The price Might pricing or
Finance or
Whatever die inventory Might come from a
Different logical Services logical
service and  That's how we build up Our
user Interface and youl notice that even
Those mics They don't have to
communicate with each
other
ok
this
History on That We Started Out With
functions in structured programming and
we Now have functions again in Azure
functions and AW lambas  That's for
Another Talk The Thing Is They Are
Calling each other with RPC all over the
time and if we go back to Services
Perhaps service Architecture
this person already
unon
name we need inversion of Communication
and supplement service oriented
Architecture with Event driven
Architecture If We Look  at Event driven
If Services Can't Call each other They
Still have to somehow be in
sync do that using publish
subs
Sharing business data because It Cross
The boundaries that means that Every
Event we publish is extremely
small Right we Won't Be publishing An
Event called order Shipping address for
example because that means that someone
Else Might receive it but we Might have
an Event saying order
accepted order
ID
weic
Apparently order is aced I invoice order
I about
prices product prices I know how to
calculate order et even I don  't know the
of the
product in St I don't My responsibility
SLE
Event order ID Again we communicate
address no use
it dealing prices
discounts in
Event
ex order
AC other also re The
Event prepare for example package
Whatever as soon ases order paid with
Again Just order ID then It thinks ok
ied all the Events that I need let ship
order
i
contain containers containers Anyway I
also Shipping address Because I The
technical Authority of my business
capability
One More Thing If We Look at it again
and say Customer became preferred  and
provide
exer
my Customer preference It Knows a bus Event
com in evenly Don't Know Why The
Customer preference That's What I mentioned
earlier If I don't share data someone
Else Can't Make decisions based on
What's Mine But I do know that  I need to
ship faster or Maybe use a Different
Packaging Again Because of
This And Never Ever is this business
data
shared services finally autonomous not
like
moving and end up with really hard
boundaries between Our Services that
have the proper encapsulation and we
Might call them Right  sized Services but
they are logical so you Won't find Them
as a Thing Inside Visual Studio or Jet
Rider Whatever You're
using this entire pillar like I It owns
user Interface data
[Music]
ins we compon process
EV decis
Bas
Event
sourcing single  solution that fits we
sourcing espe
techn
cyri bom
it mentioned and I agree with it If
currently a big B of Mud w go to micr
Services Don't immediately Go there
because end Up distrib B of
try
modic
lalic
[Music] even
small If  You Build Out Beautiful
Architecture with Customer product you
other stuff like bitcoins and ebooks and
your system Started Growing and Growing
bigger and bigger into unable
Night
Do
based on
Events Create a very Component that is
hosted some completely Else Maybe with
Own database I don't
know somewhere else you start publishing
an Event because That's basically A
single Line of code in your current
monolith where you tell Another
Component Something happened and The
Other Component starts deciding on What
Should happen
more more
of the
boundary
means B datab MP databases May micros
date This Is breaking up the big B of
spaghetti
Another that I To Age with imping Else
Don't Roll your start
Messaging use a proper framework This is
random framework
in Anyway I think microservices
is
boundaries
subscribe events Architecture Whatever
that
means publishing Events end autonomous
Services each
of
microservices
is I CH title of my Slide A Little Bit
because autonomous microservices was
clickbait I Still delivered on my
Promise To Explain to
you things shouldn't share
data If You w know More i created a
Presentation on eventual consistency
that was also  recorded uh at ndc in Oslo
about eventual consistency where i demo
some of this stuff eh but There are More
sessions this ndc in Porto for example
leela has two sessions ehm especially
The Messaging part Might be interesting
and William has also really good session
about some More  examples and youl Have A
Love or two or Five or I don't know what
else ehm While he explains this
SS
I time to visit Them I'm Denis from St If
You Go to this link youl find the
previous one Again as well including  An
Offer from me that if you ever to talk
about this More outside of ndc or want
to learn How to introduce Messaging or
Event driven Architecture Whatever
Inside Your
Organ
no 4
slides